[Musik]
wie sie wissen seiner vielen sätze eher
diskret und laufen unterhalb der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung ab also
grundsätzlich sagen zu tun mit unseren
drei kernaufgaben die sich in spezial
aufklärung command unternehmen um
militärische unterstützung und daneben
gibt es ganz viele einsätze wo sie es
gar nicht daran denken würden wo man als
soldaten braucht die rasch verfügbar
sein die ja breite ausbildung haben
spezialisierte ausrüstung mitbringen um
den jeden ort der welt gehen können egal
ob das frieden ist oder krisengebiet
oder kriegsgebiet egal ob wüste oder
dunkel oder arktis egal ob ausland oder
inland es keine zivile
großschadensereignisse beispielsweise
sein
selbst wo im einsatz im november 2000 in
kaprun beim funkenfeuer 2004 im dezember
beim tsunami und erst jüngst vor einigen
wochen war ich kann man dann deines
teams und wir haben das außenministerium
unterstützt dabei staatsbürger aus
kopitz 19 gefährdeten gebieten wieder
rück zu holen rückholung im folgenden
das gebiet des personal recovery und das
ist den spezialeinsatzkräften zugeordnet
personal kabarett musik unterlegt
militärisch sein so wie man es kennt das
movies wie zb usw
wir haben doch viel eher sagen wir
wollen 2011 im arabischen frühling mit
von der partie und thomas ägypten und
libyen menschen heim geholt wir wollen
2015 im einsatz um aus der türkei nach
dem gescheiterten putsch leute
heimzuholen und home also erfahrung
damit es große menschenmengen aus
angstbesetzten umgebungen in einer
instabilen situation geordnet an bord
eines flugzeuges zu bekommen sie während
des fluges zu betreuen sind logisch auch
medizinisch man dies notwendig werde wie
im ausrüstung mit um verfügen über
erweiterte kenntnisse und geben sie aber
wieder geordnet ab
das muss sein wir gewohnt dass wir uns
in umgebungen bewegen die kontaminiert
sein denken sie an afrika das oft genug
ebola atomare bedrohung ein thema wir
haben gelernt in unserem überlebens
ausbildungen maßnahmen der basis hygiene
und wenden es auch anders geht eine
fleisch und blut überall im größten
stress oder in der höchsten erschöpfung
für uns sein dinge wie schutzanzug wir
schutzmaske wie eigenen dekontamination
nichts neues eigentlich fängt jeder
unsere einsätze damit an dass wir uns in
isolation begeben
das bedeutet wir hatten alle
verbindungen nach außen also keine
persönlichen kontakte per telefon per
internet-chat kann nichts mehr um den
einsatz zu planen vorzügen durchzuführen
und erst nach erfolgter nachbereitung
gebe wieder aus isolation und home
wieder kontakte nach außen erleichterung
stellte sie vor wo es am flughafen das
kann das marrakesch sein das kann das
perus sein es kann es rom sein
es ist die abflughalle oder des kay
bommer bis zu 300 personen kopf
österreicher europäische staatsbürger
sprachbarriere außen ist ja instabile
situation jack bauer musste legitimieren
alles trägt maske gerüchte gehen herum
nichts ist verifiziert und dann kommt
jemand trägt rot weiß rot spricht sie an
um ihrer landessprache stellt sich vor
gibt ihnen informationen gibt einen
geordneten ablauf vor wo sie sie
einfügen können und klarerweise fühlt
man sich erleichtert und das gefühl wenn
ihr dem folge und das mache was er sorgt
wird alles gut werden
und er beschreibt wie wir sind um die
wahrgenommen werden wollen
es fängt an mit wir leben und kämpfen in
der gemeinschaft wie erfüllen schwierige
aufträge durch unkomplizierte lösungen
wir fühlen uns einem hohen persönlichen
leistungsstandard verpflichtet wir
ertragen unannehmlichkeiten und
entbehrungen wir glauben an
traditionelle werte wie kameradschaft
wie disziplin wie fürsorge wie
eigenverantwortung und vor allen dingen
wir lassen keinen kameraden zurück
[Musik]